bobby you um you've done a lot of great
work
but right now one of your biggest
missions is shining a light on this
vaccine
you want to talk about earth yeah
sure if you want i've left it
yeah and i really wanted to talk about
that yeah
yeah absolutely
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hotbox and i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson like we've got an
american
heirloom in here this is a very
interesting situation we have here
yes yes absolutely robert f kennedy jr
welcome to the hot box
my brother thank you for having me evan
mike
oh no no i'm just happy you're here
listen we were gonna um
listen we were gonna start at that stuff
what evan was talking about
but i want to go i want to go early some
real early stuff with you
listen i was raised by a guy
that was born in 1908.
um so by the time he's um
12 years old or something 20 you're 20
years old 1920 by the time he's by the
time he's 20
his family name joe kennedy is a
powerhouse a
juggernaut an american
you know so i'm a 14 year old kid 13
and i'm being raised in a household with
um
an immigrant ukrainian woman that's
80 years old at the time 85 probably
and cuss was 75 78 at the time
and talked they talked about the
experience and all the
rumors that they heard about your
grandfather and so your grandfather
more so than anybody because of his
relationships with the people that he
was related
to had relationships with blew my mind
when i was a young kid
i didn't even know a person like that
could exist it was like royalty in
america yeah right
you must have heard those stories too
well i know a lot of stories about my
family
yeah he was man he was really i mean my
grandfather
i was very close to my grandfather when
i was a little boy
let me just say this excuse my voice
i had a very very strong voice i was 42
years old
and i got a disease called spasmodic
estonia
and it makes my voice tremble
particularly when i first start talking
usually when my voice warms up it gets
better so
hopefully it will get better but in the
morning like you know right now it's
often really bad
but my um you know i my grandfather and
grandmother were
joseph kennedy rose kennedy were major
figures in my life
um we were all raised all of their 29
grandchildren kind of as one family they
had nine kids
29 grandchildren we were all raised in
adjoining houses
in a little village seaside village
board
and we would go from when i was very
very young he had uh
my grandfather had a horse farm in
barnstable about 10 miles away
and he would take us horseback riding
every morning
so we would get up at six and we would
ride with him and then we would come
home and eat breakfast
and then go to mass with my grandmother
she went to daily mass usually twice a
day
and um you know she was
very interested in history and
particularly american history
they were irish catholics from boston
eventually
left massachusetts because of the
bigotry towards irish my grandmother's
father was the first
irish catholic mayor of boston honey
vets they called him
honey yeah because
he had a beautiful voice he had a
beautiful singing voice
and he would summons people she
my grand great grandmother josie
fitzgerald who i knew
um did not want to be involved in
politics so my grandfather
and my great-grandfather honey that's
relied on his daughter rose kennedy
and she could speak seven languages and
she could play the piano beautifully
he would have torchlight parades in
boston where they would have a flat car
that was hauled by mules and there was a
piano on it
and she would play the piano and uh
honey this would sing sweet adeline and
summons the crowd
um you know he was a very very popular
mayor
one of his political rivals was patrick
joseph kennedy
who was another irishman their parents
all came over in 1848 during the famine
to boston
my great great-great-grandfather on my
um
on you know joseph kennedy's grandfather
was a cooper which means he made barrels
and then a his family started a bar
and then they went into he went into
politics and patrick joseph kennedy was
a politician a rival of honey fitz but
they were friends
and their children married and um
my grandfather joseph kennedy was one of
the first
irish catholics to go to harvard
people say that he was involved in
bootlegging but it's not true
that story in fact was invented by a guy
called sam halpern
who was a c.i.a official after
my uh uncle after president kennedy's
death and
he had a job of of besmirching the
kennedy family name for about 40 years
and that's one of the um you know that's
one of the things that he invented about
my grandfather my grandfather was a
uh he was the youngest banker in the
world
yeah he was 24 years old
and he became ambassador to england he
was
the only wealthy democrat
to support franklin roosevelt he was the
only wealthy wall street person to
support franklin roosevelt and he became
roosevelt's treasurer
and did a um a national
whistle-stop tour with roosevelt and
then when roosevelt
was trying to solve the collapse on wall
street he created
the sec the securities and exchange
commission
and since my grandfather was the only
business person on his team he became
the head of the sea city
and they you know they restored faith in
wall street
and kind of as a reward for that my
grandfather was given the post of
ambassador to
england wow
so that's his story huh that was part of
it
so this guy is sam halpern
yeah and i've written a book that i
actually gave
you guys yeah i'm stoked to dive into
that yeah i know you haven't read it
yeah because i only gave it to you
the book is really a chronicle of
my family's 60-year battle with the
c.i.a
interesting did that start with your
grandfather it started with my
grandfather
you would think with the reputation that
joe kennedy had that he was part of the
c.i.a
he didn't like the city and my
uncle john kennedy my grandfather sat on
a commission
um during the uh during the eisenhower
administration
and he said it was called the hoover
commission it was also called the david
bruce commission
and they looked at what the cia was
doing with
its secret operations around the world
and they thought it was a
catastrophe for america and for
democracy my grandfather
had a very strong belief that america
could not be an imperial power abroad
and continue to be a democracy at home
he felt that if we continued to be a
military power abroad we were going to
become a national security state at home
and we would lose our democratic rights
which is exactly what i think we became
i think that
what he predicted is what we've become i
think we're a national security
state now and we're we've devolved away
from
democracy more and more towards a
corporate kleptocracy and
um you know eisenhower
on my birthday in 1960 jess
eisenhower gave his last speech in
political office
just before my uncle took the oath of
office and eisenhower warned america
that the greatest threat to democracy
was not a foreign enemy but the
military-industrial complex which he
said would rob everything that we value
about this country
and i think my uncle spent the next
three years fighting
against the military and the
intelligence apparatus
um and i think you know and he was
killed and then my father
ran for office campaigning against that
cartel um campaigning against the
vietnam war and he was also killed and i
think our country
since that time has been going down the
path
of you know of becoming a national
security
state so interesting eisenhower warned
against that
as a general it is you know
it's historically it has been
the people who actually experienced war
in this country
the presidents who actually experienced
war who have done the most to try to
keep us out of war
and my uncle president kennedy is an
example you know he was and his brother
was killed in the war joe can't even see
each other
oh county junior his his brother-in-law
my aunt kick's husband was killed right
at the beginning of the war
um uh andrew capendish
and um and then he lost a lot of his
crew
and he was lost at sea and and presumed
dead after his ship was run over by a
japanese destroyer in the blackened
straits near the solomon island
and he was rescued ultimately by a
solomon island
native and he uh
but he lost a lot of his groom a lot of
his friends were killed and my
uncle was asked by ben bradley he was
one of his best friends who was the
publisher of the washington post
what do you want your epithet to be and
my on
my uncle's head he wanted his epithet to
be quote
he kept the peace and quote he said the
primary job of
every president he believed was to keep
this country out of war
and he had the entire military complex
of this country
and the intelligence apparatus trying to
get him to go into laos trying to get
him to go into berlin
trying to get him to go into and during
his thousand days in office he refused
to send a single combat troop abroad
he did send sixteen
thousand advisers ultimately under huge
pressure
to vietnam who technically weren't
allowed to fight
but that's fewer people fewer troops
than he sent to the university of
mississippi
one black man james meredith admitted
into that university
so it was a very very small commitment
relatively
um he also avoided the
cuban missile crisis right and the
military network gave him for that
or the bay of bigs they wanted to
overthrow castro
yeah and you know you had and the cia
that was
in league with the mafia with you know
sam g and kana and with carlos marcelo
and um
and trafficante who was the tampa boss
all of whom
had these big casinos in havana
at castro had closed so they
wanted to kill castro and the cia wanted
to kill castro and they made a
partnership
and by the end of by 1960
even by the time my uncle became
president it was
almost impossible to distinguish where
the cia ended
and where the mafia began because they
were so intertwined in all of their
planning and operations
interesting and i guess you know i just
stick to joe kennedy because he made all
this into existence
you know that's right well he's right
that's why i'm a strong fan of joe
kennedy
because this doesn't exist this is his
this is his vision
before the kids even existed this is his
vision
you know he saw those guys he saw
rockefeller and those guys and
vanderbilt
and um he saw those guys with all that
power getting even more powerful
you know i mean he had and in his mind
in some way that he had to embed in that
and that's why he wanted the sons to be
pregnant well you know my
my grandmother had
in their house they had a bunch of
newspaper articles that were mounted a
lot of
pictures of honey fitz and patrick
kennedy
and she had one that i remember of my
uncle
of my great-grandfather honey it's
flying in one of the first biplanes
i was right after the airplane was
invented and you know
it was a picture of him flying in that
plane
and she would take that picture of the
frame
and she always which was a picture from
the newspaper
she would show us the backside of it and
the backside of it were classified
advertisements looking you know
advertising for job placements
under each of the little boxes where
they advertised where they you know the
the advertisement was it was the phrase
nina
n-i-n-a and that meant no
irish need apply and she would show us
that and say you know this is
um this is why we left boston that's why
we moved to new york
wow wow but in the movie the gang's in
new york it was the irish that didn't
want the irish to come to new york yeah
oh the ones that were there already
already situated and had everything
under control they didn't want these
irish
to come to america yeah we have a
complex history
[Music]
i know so would you say that
since joe and probably before him even
the kennedy family has been a family for
the people
well honey fitz was you know the first
member of our family in politics you
have to remember that
in ireland it was illegal for catholics
to hold political office they couldn't
be in any profession
since 1691 they couldn't be an
attorney they couldn't vote
they couldn't hold political office in
fact it was illegal
um during most of that history for
irish to learn to read or write they
were slaves when they first came here
huh when they first came here yeah they
were earth they were
most of them came to escape the famine
and the famine was not a natural famine
it was an engineered famine
because there was plenty of food in
ireland for
in british warehouses for the irish to
eat but the british would not share
with them and the british had forced the
irish because the irish weren't allowed
to own land
the land was all on by the british and
they wanted to grow the cash crop
rather than subsistent crops they grew
potatoes which was
shippable crack cash crop and when the
potatoes
a mold and faded the potatoes in 1848
and destroyed them all
and millions of irish died almost
i think there were six million irish and
a million died
and two million left the country mainly
for australia or the united states
and the atlantic um was called by james
joyce a bowl of bitter tears
and the irish and landed on the shores
here
were mainly illiterate james joyce is
the great irishman
yeah yeah and they were poor but they
also
were tremendously interested in
literature
because they've been starved from it in
poetry
and in politics because and they took
the politics like a starving
man takes the food and they were
naturals at it as
you know they showed in the gangs of new
york they were
they they soon came to dominate almost
all the urban
centers in america as they flooded in
and they
you know and and local politicians would
take control so
honey fitz was the first ghetto irish to
be elected
in boston and he then went to congress
and in congress he passed a law
making it illegal to have
language requirements for new immigrants
because he was trying to protect the
italian
immigrants because people you know in
many parts of the united states
um there were laws being passed with an
effort to keep italians from voting
and so they had to pass literacy tests
and my grandfather passed a law saying
you couldn't give those kind of literacy
tests
and anybody who's familiar with civil
rights history knows
that's the way that you know that um
during the jim crow days in the south
that literacy tests were the primary
mechanism for keeping
african-americans from absolutely
absolutely
i am aware you know a lot of those
african civil rights leaders
were taught to read by um communist
civil you know those um
intellectual communists but also the
boards
attested them in the south i were
but they were all a little made up of
whites
illiterate but even the ones who weren't
illiterate like booker t
washington you know was read
read the constitution and then was
quizzed on it
asked everything you know we answered
every question perfectly we
were still denied the right to vote
because it was a white panel
and if a white farmer came in who
couldn't read and
asked him to sign his name they'd say
you can vote
so they had different roles applying
listen intellectuality it's not forget
about politics and stuff just you as
your life
you must have seen everything at all
such a different level you want to see
ass kissing at a different level you
must have seen power
different who have you seen in your
house who came to your house
really who says it's your family well
am i yeah
i would say
almost anybody i mean hickory oh which
was
all your family those guys came hanging
out with you guys not
the queen of england no about sons
virtually all the presidents
have been at you know at my a house i
was
raised and it was hickory almost did you
go to school with the bushes and stuff
did you know
coming up nope
your father knew them when he was
younger your father and your uncle
i knew them i ran into something in
politics
you know i ran into them in the 1980
political campaigns and um
george bush when he was c.i.a the first
president
was my mother had a um
had a zipline at her house that was
installed by the
uh by the green berets my family was
very very close to
the green berets because president
kennedy when he was president the
pentagon did not want them to wear a
brace and my uncle was
he he sort of kind of saw a special
forces
as a peace corps with guns and
he believed that they rightly wrongly
that they could be used to keep us at
major wars and that they would be the
equivalent of the communist guerrillas
who would go into
countries and convert um
you know local populations that
they would have the same role so he
believed strongly and
he wanted to wear a beret the pentagon
didn't want
any soldier right my uncle
passed an executive order that allowed
them
to keep them right in front and on we
had a very very close relationship to
them and they
would come to our house but they built
an obstacle course at our home
including a very very dangerous zip line
that a lot of people
went on that zipline a lot of people
went to the hospital because it went
from the top of very hill to the bottom
and there was no
break on it somebody had to grab the
rope and in fact
mom not lee was on at and fell
oh my god and uh but but
george bush went on it when he was vice
president
which showed a lot of courage
do you ever meet gene cunning yes i knew
he
um he was close to my grandfather i
could imagine that yeah
and he you know one of the things about
him he was a very literate man he was
the first one
yeah well his his son antonio
his name was barrack honey or john
donney
is my uncle teddy's best friend gene
tony he was
called the newscaster women wasn't no no
he was john tunney was senator from
california yeah i remember that one
and he went to university of virginia
law school with my uncle but
jeans honey the fighter who um
uh you know that famous fight dempsey
and ferpo he became
he he was my grandfather joseph got his
golfing partners kind of favorite him
and cardinals feltman
where cardinal cushing would all golf
together
and he was a literate man and he had i
forgot how many fights but he had about
25
fights oh he
while he was practicing for a fight he
would memorize
a play of shakespeare and that's one of
the kind of mental disciplines that wow
and emerald is all that you know there's
a book about him and george bernard shaw
they went on a vacation a trip together
it's called the
what was called the boxer and the writer
the poet whatever him and jim
um george bernard shaw yeah he went on a
trip together wow
and he was golfing buddies with joe as
well
yeah that's crazy that's crazy
have you seen the movie the irishman
yeah
yeah yes um how does that
ring as far as your uncle
and everything it's not you know
i actually like that movie a lot and i
think you know but
like my kids walked out of it because it
was two hours too long but
i couldn't watch it for another two
hours yeah
i thought it was great it was great i
thought it was great just watching those
actors the other one i really liked was
uh the tarantino of a list of times
hollywood yeah and my kids also who
loved
tarantino did not like that movie
because yeah i liked it i loved that
movie
as well and just watching those guys
acting yes oh great
yeah so great in terms of the treatment
of my family
it's not historically accurate um
my the idea that i'm sam samji
and kana had anything to do
with helping the kennedys during the
1960 election in chicago which is
another
myth that was started by sam halpern
interesting
is it's it's totally implausible
actually i was at you know my father
had been prior to the presidency the
biggest scourge that the mafia had ever
run into
my father was running the rackets your
grandfather
weren't friends they didn't know no no
my father ran the rackets committee
in the united states senate my uncle was
a senator
and it was on the rackets committee
my father was like the mueller of that
time and he was calling all the mobsters
you know
joey gallow and sam giancana and jimmy
hoff and all these people who just amped
back the people who were
tied in with the mob and for four years
he was grilling them 18 months
before the 1960 election
he grilled samji in ghana and i was
there
and because my mother would bring us
every day
and sit in the front row and watch him
and she would explain to us what was
happening
we were watching these you know major
mafia figures
sam g and khanna took the fifth i think
75 times and my father
and at one point my father said is it
true that
when somebody offends you that you kill
them and stuff them in the trunk of a
car
he said i take the and he said is it
true that you take your opponents and
hang them on meat hooks
and he said i take the f and then he
started giggling
my father said to him are you are you
giggling
mr giancana isn't that something that
only little girls did
a little girl mr gin connor wow wow
jane kind of hated my father wow and to
to say that 18 months after that
my father who ran my uncle's campaign
would have allowed anything
to do with sam g and conor or that
giancana would be inclined to want to
help the kennedys in any way
and all of it and you know or the idea
that my grandfather would have gone
behind my father's back
who was running that campaign and make a
deal with a man that my father despised
and who would have had then the power
to injure the kennedys if they you know
if
he if all he'd have to do is publicly
say hey joe kennedy came to me and asked
me
you know to help him on the election oh
all of that is not only just la sheer
baloney
but it is um you know it's completely
implausible not a not only that but
what they say is that the kennedys won
the election because
you know this mafia help in chicago
this was the cia story but even if if
we had lost illinois
during the 1960 election we would have
still won the election
because we had the we didn't need the
state of illinois
and it's no doubt it was corruption and
illinois there was corruption by
republicans downstate
there was corruption by mayor daley and
his team
in chicago and they were
they were mainly and you know there were
many local investigations afterwards and
they all showed that the corruption was
designed
was targeting local campaigns local
judges
and and not the presidential campaign
they tarnished my aim and jewish his
grandfather you know
and he was a good guy
so what what was it that why did the cia
want to destroy
the kennedy families it started with my
grandfather
my grandfather um
upset a lot of people in this prime huh
in the yeah
and in the 50s he wrote a report saying
that we should abandon the clandestine
services at that point you know they had
to overthrow the government
and install the dictatorship overthrown
the first democratically elected
government in the history of iran in the
four thousand
year history of that country a very very
popular mom at mozadeg
and we had installed a dictatorship run
by the shelter and we had on the cia
had overthrown a democratically elected
government of wonderful government in
guatemala
jacob or our bands did he kill someone
i killed many many people and um
and my grandfather wrote a report saying
this is hurting america all over the
world that we're supposed to be the
friend of democracy we shouldn't be
overthrowing it
and people know what we're doing is and
you know this
service is out of control and that was
one thing and then
my uncle came in richard nixon had
planned
a biggs invasion and he had been vice
president but he was in charge he called
it his brainchild
but they had left the execution
to my uncle my uncle was very
unwilling to do it because his attitude
was
if if cuba wants to experiment with
communism
i bless them that's their right you know
we experimented with government here
if communism doesn't work for them
eventually they'll overthrow it
the worst thing would be for america to
go in and tell an independent sovereign
agent particularly in a bullying way
you can't experiment with your own form
of government
and he sent that message to castro
but a cash by the time he came in the
cia
had trained you know of the east 2000
cubans armed them train them in
guatemala
armed them and um and they were ready to
go
and my uncle said to dulles
he said you know what you can let him
he didn't want them to go at all alice
said
if we keep them here they're armed and
they're going to cause a lot of problems
you got to let them go
and there were political considerations
etc
there's a young president less than two
and a half months in office
and he said we don't we i want to make
sure
your assurance that there will be no
involvement of the us military
and they said there won't be no need as
soon as these guys
land in cuba castro's so unpopular that
there'll be a huge
uprising and they'll overthrow them they
knew dulles and bissell
and cabell the three cia chiefs
and lemitzer who was the chairman of the
joint chiefs of
all knew they were lying they all knew
that castro was immensely popular
and he had a very well trained army and
that he had an intelligence service
rivaling any in the world you ever meet
castro
uh i'm adam lotz you met jake avera
no i met castro
in fact i went with my wife cheryl hines
my children
i guess the last time i met him was
about five years ago but i've talked to
him about the assassinations
and talked to him no i'm not batista huh
did i meet batista no he was
he was long gone i suppose
he's i don't know whatever happened to
him but he went to miami i think
he must have yeah he got rid of him
quick huh yeah
well he's uh you know my uncle
president kennedy really blamed batista
for the emergence of castro
and you know and and in many ways he
cash oh embracing communism
was was our doing because castro on it
you know
first came to us camped in new york he
tried to meet
with i said or eisenhower said he was
busy playing golf
and they made it we meet with nixon and
nixon said we need to overthrow
he said i don't know if he's coming is
but he may be under communist influence
and we need to overthrow
and then we started you know making war
on him
and he and we close standard oil clothes
the only oil refinery in cuba which was
a chokehold on their economy
the cubans said first of all
united fruit stopped buying their sugar
so that shut down their economy so they
made a deal with russians okay you send
it so oil
sent you sugar and you know we treated
that as an act of war but really it was
an act of survival
and then the cia started bombing them
they bombed a
shopping center in havana and killed a
lot of people and at that point
castro said okay we're going to be
communists that's what we're being
accused of that's what we're
going to do it's all may
he said i was always got minutes
jay was communist because jay was in
guatemala
in 1954 when we when the cio
overthrew our bans he was working in a
hospital taking care of poor people
there
and that transformed him into a
communist but
the people who came over with castro
from mexico on the
you know they had a they had a boat
cabin cruiser called the abuela there
was
i think 70 people on it who were all
soldiers
and castro told me i said did you choose
them because they had
a big force in in mexico they were
trending and i said did you
judge the ones who were hardcore
communists
and he said no the only criteria we had
for who went on the abuela
was their size because we only wanted
small people so we could fit more people
onto the boat
because it was a tiny little boat and he
said
most of the people on the abuela were
not communists
these were those you know the guys who
started who triggered the revolution
from
andre and so it was interesting
you know it's fascinating yeah i think
your life is
more important talking about your stuff
your family's all close how did you feel
when john
jr um went through that accident oh of
course i felt very bad he was like my
brother
oh you know him and mike had a pretty
close relationship
he interviewed george
he came to see me when i was in prison
too
that's how i met him he was an
interesting guy and
it was very interesting yeah i was crazy
i really had a lot of weight on his
shoulders huh
uh-huh and then being that many me and
jackie
he carried it very well he was a very
happy fun
fun-loving he was very gifted
in many many ways um he was an amazing
storyteller
he had a gift for mimicry he could
mimic any um any
like whether you were russian or irish
he could do
he was he was interested in the art
and he was interested in the arts he was
incredibly knowledgeable about
history philosophy art science he's just
an all-around really
interesting guy hmm so listen
what do you think do you think he was
like um he was like selectively bread
oh john yeah like his his his
father probably said this is a this is a
great um
future leader yeah future wife no the to
his wife oh
john's mother well i think john my
uh that's what they did this is the best
one yeah but that's not like
that family that's not what that's what
happened
for our family nobody would put up with
that my uncle married
jackie because you know she was
an amazing catch and he loved her
really my grandfather really had a close
relationship with her
he really um when
he when he hit dinner at his house he
always jackie next to him
she was an incredible conversation she
was she was my son bobby's
godmother but she was you know
she had an extraordinary intellectual
curiosity
um she had an extraordinary life
and she was interested in everything she
spoke um
half a dozen languages she was
interested in how other people
lived in history you know she edited
books
because she loved knowledge do you from
your experience spending whether you
believe that she was a happy person do
you believe
life really hit a heart i i think that
she was
you know like any of us like nobody's
happy all the time
you know we all are lucky that we
experience
um moments of joy in our life and we're
lucky if we can enjoy them and be
grateful
i think she practiced being grateful
and that she i think she was like
like most of that generation of my
family
she was absolutely destroyed
for several years after my uncle's death
and then
you know she was completely in love with
my father
and when my father died i think she just
felt like the world had ended
hmm
that's just so devastating did you know
her mother
i'm each accused mother out and at all
she was very interested who was that guy
her father was an interesting guy
blackjack
jacob i saw a picture in the movie of
janet and
and um jackie and there's a picture of
blackjack
with um her mother by holding her
mother's friend's hand
that's a possibility yeah after that
picture they were at a whole they were
sitting at a horse ranch
who was blackjack where did that was
after that
what did he do he uh he was there too
wasn't he a man
he was a very you know he was a
he was a very wealthy kind of
sportsman and as mike points out that he
was
had a reputation of being a playboy but
he looked no
interesting he looks a lot like um john
jr
yeah he looked filming and they called
him blackjack because he had
very very thick black hair yeah great
john
yeah same here exactly at the same time
i looked at it wow you look like john
same here wow wow
um do you do you feel like was the cia
involved in the assassination of your
uncle
um i would say yes yeah i mean it's very
well established now that
and your father even well let me
let you know let me talk about two
things
absolutely winning season returns at my
bookie
winning season means doubling down your
first deposit
winning season means insane props epic
bonuses
and the craziest cross-sports wages at
my book you want to see the means
watching live sports and betting live
sports all season long
rejoice the nfl has returned and that
means action-packed sundays
and huge cash prizes get in on the
action
and use promo code tyson and double your
first deposit
the new players get up to a thousand
dollars in free play
designed to add more excitement to the
sport that you love
and the game that you love to bet on
that was the best in the nfl season
for your chance to win big okay use
promo code tyson and double your your
first
deposit your winning season begins today
only at my bookie
i think the evidence of cia involvement
with president kennedy's assassination
is incontrovertible at this point
including i think it's incontrovertible
that
lee harvey oswalt was acid
since 1956.
um that he was recruited by james jesus
angleton who was head of counter
intelligence
his bro he was at that time a marine and
he was a radar operator
at um at the uh
at the uh u2 air base in japan
and then he defected to the soviet union
but it was a false affection he
actually we now know that he defected
that he was being used as a cia as what
they call a dangle
there was a soviet mole in langley
and nobody could figure out who it was
but they but it had
they had exposed every soviet spy since
the beginning of the agency
they were trying to expose ankleton was
trying to expose the soviet mall so
he put a tag a trigger on oswald's file
at langley and then got oswald to fake
this affection
hoping that the mole would be contacted
by their
um kgb superiors and told go look at the
oswald file and find out who this guy
is and anybody who touched that file
they wouldn't know who did it
and it never happened and so oswald was
then recalled
and he came back to the united states in
60
i'm 62 without it ever being punished
without ever being supposedly questioned
by the cia
the state department paid his way home
they sent him to dallas
and in dallas he was met
by a cia assets taken care of placed in
the job at the book depository
etc all of that is very very well
documented
in terms of my father you know
here's what we now know about and i
always um
when i was a little kid i assumed that
my uncle was killed by you know some
kind of a conspiracy and which is what
the
united states said in the united states
congress during their investigations
made the same conclusion
and the warren commission did not but
the warrant commission
was run by alan dulles who was the head
of the c.i.a
and who my uncle had fired and
he became he inculcated himself onto the
warren commission
and and lied you know kept them away
from the cfa
and basically produced a fake report
and when the church committee came
you know in 1972 73 74 and investigated
it
they said it was certainly a conspiracy
but i assume that from the beginning
because i was in the white house you
know my uncle's body was in the white
house we
waked in there and i was there with my
father and my
aunt um jackie
and a bunch of my cousins and brothers
when lyndon johnson came in
the two days after my uncle was killed
and said that
lee harvey oswald had been shot by jack
ruby
and he thought was all that news and i
went to my father
and my mom and said why did he do that
did he love our family
and way wow dude because were you why
would he done it
yeah right and i was if to me i was a
little kid
you know little 10 year old kid saying
why wow
i do it it turned on my father's initial
reaction was that
see i had killed his brother he
um you know he questioned uh uh
he questioned all ahead of this yeah at
a time and
a bunch of his contacts in the cuban
division cia
and then um two years later he asked
frank mc
said walter sheridan who was his kind of
security guy
to look into jack ruby
and what they found was that ruby not
only
had was a mobster who worked for the
giancana family and was presently
working for carlos marcelo's family
which was
all tied in with the cia he was also a
gun runner for this yeah
cuba um so
i but i always assume that my father
that's her hand killed my father
and because her hannah confessed to it
and there
and you know there was a trial
supposedly
but a couple of years ago when i started
investigating it for this book that i
was writing
it you know i i looked at the paul
charade who was with my father when he
was shot
as a union leader one of the heads of
the
united auto workers he was the guy who
recruited
cesar chavez into the labor movement
and and he introduced them to my father
and they became best friends
and so paul was very very close
and was with him the first bullet
her hand fired um hit pause made in the
head
and paul aide has never believed
that sir and killed my father wow
he knows that he
paul forced me to sit down to read the
autopsy report stuff
i never wanted to do and to look at all
the evidence that has accumulated since
my father's death
and so ethel is your mother right
right oh sorahan
was it was 77 eyewitnesses
in the kitchen the ambassador hotel my
father was killed
and many many of them had a a
a view of what happened a very few of
them could view the whole scene but they
could view parts of that
everybody without exception places her
hand
from five feet to ten feet
away from my father in front of him he
never got behind him
he was always in front with a table
between them
a steam table sarahan
fired two shots of my father
the first one he hit balls right in the
head the second one he hit a door jamb
at my father's head level behind my
father
then he was grabbed by carl alter who
was the
um who was the concierge at the
ambassador hotel
and by rayford johnson and six other
people
it was a dog pile and they all piled on
him and they grabbed
the first thing they did was grab his
hand
they directed in the opposite direction
and they could not get the gun away from
him and he was powerful
as a like a superman they said
they were all trying to take the gun
away
is a little guy and he fired six shots
in the other direction and all of them
hit people
one person got hit twice but all those
bullets are accounted for there were
only
eight chambers in his gun
and two were fired toward my father in
six in the opposite direction and we
know what happened to every one of those
bullets
my father was shot four times
one of their shots and he all four times
were from behind
and with a gun that was um
that was and they were all what the
coroner thomas
gucci said contact shots
the barrel that gun was touching my
father
when the when the trigger was pulled and
he had carbon tattoos from all four
shots one of the shots went harmlessly
through his sleeve
and through his shoulder pad all of the
shots were fired from a low angle toward
the ceiling
whoever fired those shots was standing
behind him concealing the gun
and firing at the same time that zeran
was
distracting people essentially
and the person who almost certainly
fired those shots was a security guard
who was holding my father's arm at that
time called eugene's
ain't caesar and a dozen people
saw him with his gun drawn my father
fell back on him
and as he fell he turned and pulled off
as a star's clip untie
caesar lied to the police about this gun
he told many many different stories
about when he had drawn his gun
he lied he said he did own at 22. the
police didn't
talk to him and i didn't confiscate his
gun
the time they talked to him he said yeah
i owned it 22 but i sold it a month
before the shooting
as it turns out that was a lie he sold
it a month
after the shooting and he sold it to a
man who worked at him
with him in the high security section of
the lockheed factory here in los
angeles who then moved to arkansas
later talked to investigators and said
yeah he had a receipt from when he was
sold and it was sold in july my father
was killed in june
and caesar told him at that time
um this gun was used in a crime so don't
talk to anybody about it
a caesar it as it turns out
what is ac i said he died about three
weeks ago
and he died in the philippines where
he's lived for the past three decades
and um but he's almost certainly the
person who who killed my father now
his job as a security guard
that he got five days before
when it was already known that my father
was going to be speaking there
we don't know exactly what happened but
there are
and then you know the investigation was
a botched investigation appears to have
been deliberately botched by the lapd
it was run by people within the lapd
all of whom had they were there was a
special
unit created called special unit senator
to investigate my father's
death almost all the members of that
unit were xcia
agents who had um trained
in the cia farm in in virginia
and shipped down to latin america to do
dirty tricks work there and then brought
back for this investigation
and they destroyed before seren's trial
they they destroyed 1200 pieces of
evidence
all including all the bullets
and i and and about
1200 photographs as well that were taken
in the room that night
um so
um you know there's a lot of questions
there's never there really
i believed that there had been a trial
as it turns out there was a trial
sergeant's attorney
was an attorney who
somehow and nobody can explain how
he was a mob attorney who was
representing johnny roselli
who had been at that time there was a
famous trial in los angeles called the
friars
club trial you know what the friars club
is
please what is that for irish club
is why they started roasts oh okay
and it was it was all the rat pack
um actors joey bishop and frank sinatra
and dean and dean martin davis
yeah all of those guys were members of
friar club and they'd get together every
couple of months and rose one of their
members
and to get in there he had to be wearing
a tux
and they also had a gambling uh a poker
game or a gambling casino i'm not sure
which but there was a poker game
in there and as it turns out johnny
roselli was the owner of the club johnny
roselli was the cia's
liaison to the mark wow that's a trip
you know i used to read about him
he was in the 20s too yeah he was an
interesting guy he was a
devout catholic he didn't have a home
address
um but he was tied in with gian connor
but also carlos masala
and trafficante he had
installed secret cameras in the friars
club so they could read everybody's
cards
and they were cheating he got caught
and he was on trial at the time my
father was killed
it was a huge trial during that trial
his attorney got arrested
for having the grand jury
transcripts which is illegal for anybody
to have it's a serious crime you go to
jail for it
and somehow he had got the transcripts
of the grand jury so
um and clearly the mafia had to bribe
somebody to get that
given it to the attorney the attorney
wouldn't tell where he got it but he was
facing criminal charges also
disappointment
and in the middle of all that he was
somehow
appointed as her hand's attorney
he told her hand to plead guilty um if
sir and had
pleaded innocent there was no way that
he could have gotten convicted because
the bullets
that were in his gun the bullets that
killed my father did not
match the ballistics of the bullets in
his gun or the bullets that hit the
other
eight people in the world cover up big
time whoa
um but he was told and so anyway
now surya has no memory has said since
that
eighties no memory of what happened but
there's a lot of hints about kind of
how he got in that state is he in prison
yeah he's in prison i actually went to
see him about
he's like 70 maybe 75 or something
wow i went and met with him
about i don't know last year
so bobby how do you
you know both your father and your uncle
your really your i mean your your whole
lineage your family lineage has been
about
in a big way to me
protecting the people or being for the
people's rights and
you know your uncle had that you know
going back to this
feud with the cia he had that whole
speech about doing away with secret
societies
and getting rid of these clandestine
oscillations
um and do you
feel like how do you
interpret this in yourself like is this
about
is this almost sort of
i don't want to say the price but of
standing up for what's good and right
in the world shining the light into the
darkness
like how do you rectify this in yourself
you know i don't really think about it
in those terms i think they uh
you know they had a very idealistic view
of this country
they thought america they saw america as
an exemplary nation they felt that we
were
and and by that i mean in the best sense
of the word that we
were supposed to be an example a shining
example of what human beings could
accomplish
through self-governance um
in a humane and just and democratic
system
they believed in free market capitalism
but they believed in a humane system and
they also believed that the biggest
injury to our country
would come from entanglements foreign
entanglements that would
um that would make that would turn us
into a militarized nation
[Music]
and they spent a lot of time fighting
that
and i you know i think to me that is the
most important part of their legacy
um you know i think they were they did
have a battle with the cia
and i think um
you know that probably had something to
do with both of their deaths
and i won my championship on november
22nd
which championship my first championship
in 1986
november 22nd wow
that's president kennedy's anniversary
of this death yeah
wow that's interesting
like how did you decide to put a tattoo
on your face
i just thought um that was who i was
yeah that's a real commitment
i don't know life is life is a
commitment yeah
[Laughter]
um
bobby you um you've done a lot of
great work as well yourself with the
environment
your environmental initiatives but
right now one of your biggest missions
is shining a light on this vaccine
do you want to talk about birds first
yeah yeah
sure if you want i'd love to hear
is yeah and i really want to talk about
that
yeah yeah absolutely
unlike me i've been with birds i've been
flying brothers since i was nine years
old
some bully kids um picked on me bullying
made me clean their pigeon coop and
be their gopher like if they're birds
they're in bad condition they're flying
they get tired they're flying under the
roof so i have to go on the roof and
scare the birds off the roof
or go to the store for these guys
because they're lazy and stuff buy them
cigarettes and buy them some juices or
cookies and stuff
and so um i just wanted to be around the
birds all the time so i was willing to
be this guy's go for a slave whatever it
before i can get more advanced and
educated on the pigeons and so um
one day i i was a little criminal cast
those i broke in somebody's house and
stole some money and stuff and i went
and bought like 100 pigeons
or more and i showed somebody all my
opinions and he went and told some other
big kids where my opinions were
and i was trying to fight and they were
stealing my birds and then my mother
came up and
came up and scared them so one guy stole
one of my birds and ran
out and i was saying please come on get
my birds back please
no you fat [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm giving you
[ __ ] and he popped my bird's head off
and
pulled blood on me and that was the
first fight i've ever had in my life
and then i kind of um i used to get
picked on all the time and then ever
since somebody saw me fight everybody
wanted me to be their friend
and that's how i began that fighting guy
i was everybody fingered i was i wasn't
afraid to fight anyone
wow and your relationship with pigeons
was
sealed in blood yeah and never said i
have him now
um you know all that today
you have birds today listen i broke my
own defense
my other phone if i would show you my
pigeon coop you would say what the hell
my pigeon coop is like a house
[Laughter]
there's no doubt about it man that's
just what it was
that's what my whole life is about
pigeons
what they got me out of um it just got
me out of trouble
i still got in trouble but it just i
wouldn't be dawg i don't have nowhere to
go because they were bullying me in
school and that's why i didn't go to
school because i
was skating in bullets i just flew
pigeons
well i started when i was around the
same age
and i got i don't get rant homers
and we would raise them i lived in
virginia at that time but we would raise
um you know you you you um when you're
raising them you go farther and farther
from your house
and train for one month you know you
have 250 miles
wow a really good one
250 even 500 miles 500 there's nothing
you know they just sold that one for 1.5
million dollars
listen i looked it up yesterday armando
he was uh
yeah two chinese bitters the chinese
people they're they're the champions now
pigeon raising chinese um
god please go that far but listen let me
explain something to you
i would go to foreign countries um
ubekistan
uh-huh moscow um it's
his name in romania i would go and i
would go around people need to be the um
administration politics the politician
and i would say hey who's the biggest
pigeon fancier around here i'll say
and they don't really and they would
take me and these guys would have pigeon
coops that would just
they would dwarf houses they look like
this and just
they must be the local crime lord or
something because they have
it's just it's amazing thousands of
acres of the farm and they have these
big elaborate pigs including cost
millions of dollars they have staff to
take care of them
and the food that feeds them constantly
the cleans they're constantly automatic
it's just you can't believe it
it's amazing the pigeon world is just
amazing why
why because um god's given us that
opportunity to intermingle with nature
you know what happened like i was
talking yesterday i had a big eagle you
know i think i'm somebody in this world
and um
i was looking at the guy wayne dyer i
was listening to a man
and he said when you look out this world
what do you see and he explains um
what you don't know you see perfection
the world is perfected already
regardless what we think about what we
think about the racism about we think
about the the politics here and
the rights and every this is perfected
who are we to question if we could
change it but this is
perfected and that's why we have um
that's why we have a complex with the
world because we don't like it
but we don't like the perfection of the
world this is the way the universe made
it
and we disagree with the universe
they just like people and all different
personalities
um you know what you can tell the
the females the males and the way that
they behave and
strategies that they use inside the coop
and
they're genius at traveling are all
things i could sit and watch pigeons for
not weeks and not get bored
i love it that's what i used to when i
used to be when i trained in another
state
another country i have people feel my
pigeons and they send me the tapes and i
watch it for hours since my pitching
another coup flying
watch them in the air flight brought
some land well they used to carry
messages too right they still do
still do israel they still do it
yeah it's amazing
so you since you were a little boy you
you raised pigeons
yeah i raised pigeons and i erased them
um and and how do you race them well you
raise
you know you train them money part
the way that we used to do it they do it
differently today but the way that we
used to do it
is we would all put our pigeons on the
same train
people from the in the same area put
them on the same train the train would
go down to delaware
sometimes people would have a truck
and the conductor would release them all
at once
your pigeon flies back into your coop
there's a pigeon door that lets him in
but he can't get out when he goes
through that
you grab the pitch and you take off his
band you run it down to the
you clock it down you have to go back
then you had to go to the post office
and get a time stamp
and that's how you would win the race
and you're you you would make your
opinions go you know you would train
them to go farther and farther and
farther so i take my parents to school
with me and release
them and you know they fly home and i'd
get somebody to drive me out of the
country and release something
the biggest race is sun city south
africa they
um they have the most multi-million
dollar race wow
have you been have you seen it mike
personally well not personally about
seeing it on film
that's amazing you can have you been
there for that
no no no i kind of switched to
hawks when i was i did too you know why
because they were attacking my bird so i
laid traps for them so i catch them
and then i start raising them yeah i was
going to say when aren't hawks
they'll predator yeah they're not
friendly with pigeons
yeah they'll eat pigeons yeah i think
i've seen i seen an eagle grab a of um
owl kilter and ate his heart
yeah yeah birds of prey man they're
vicious
um so right now
bobby you have a documentary
that's out vaxxed too
and it's really tackling this issue
of vaccines
and really the the horrible side effects
that these things
um you know this has been an issue that
my wife and i have been dealing with we
have an eight-year-old daughter and
we were talking about it a little bit
earlier but you know
vaccines we live in this
we live in this country where you know
western medicine people have
become so
dogmatized by doctors and western
medicine and
giving our health over to these health
care professionals
who you know it's it's kind of it's a
pharmaceutical model
right right rather than you know
um rather than building your immune
system
which is you know it's like a ferrari
our immune system we've kind of adopted
this pharmaceutical model which is
more about treating symptoms and
you know i'm not saying anything about
about doctors because
doctors have saved my life and i'm very
grateful in the medical profession but
sure um you know nowadays particularly
with pediatricians we're seeing this
explosion of chronic illness
in our children and it's not just
autism autism has dropped from one in
ten thousand in my generation to one in
thirty four in my kids generation
crazy it's all the allergic diseases
like peanut
allergies autoimmune diseases like
diabetes and
rheumatoid arthritis and all the
neurodevelopmental diseases
like add adhde speech delay
narcolepsy narcolepsy ticks
in autism and all of those diseases
became epidemic in 1989.
oh if you were born according to hhs
health and human services if you were
born prior
to 1989 which is the year they changed
the vaccine schedule
your chance of having a chronic disease
is 12
if you were born after 1989 it's 54
wow and all of the diseases that have
become epidemic there's about 300 of
them
in that disease what is obesity in there
obviously it's sitting there obviously
it is linked to
interesting all of those um
injuries that have become epidemic
epidemic there's about 300 diseases
every one of them are listed as side
effects
on the manufacturers inserts for the 72
vaccines that are now mandated for our
children
the thing that people have to understand
is that the four companies
and make all 72 of those vaccines
which is fizer fighters killing merck
black's own merc and sanofi
um all of those companies are convicted
felons
and not only that they're serial felons
their business model
is committing felonies these companies
in the last 10 years collectively
have paid 35 billion dollars
in penalties damages fines for
falsifying science for defrauding
regulators
lying to doctors and for killing
hundreds of thousands of people
vioxx which was merck flagship product
killed between 120 000 and 500 000
americans this was a
pill and merck was selling as a headache
pill
right and murk knew caused heart attacks
and killed people
and they didn't tell anybody and they
knew a certain you know we got the
spreadsheets that show their
be encounters their accountants and this
is
you're going to kill so many people per
dose
we can still make more money even if
they all sue us
in the end they killed you know up to
half a million americans and they got
away with it they got
they paid seven billion dollars in fines
nobody went to jail
and this is you know 100 million in
profits
yeah so this is a company
these it requires kind of a cognitive
dissonance
to believe that these companies that are
lying and cheating on
every other pharmaceutical product every
other
medical device that they create are
somehow found jesus
vaccines that aren't lying to us and the
thing is with vaccines
vaccines the only place they could never
get caught
because it's illegal in this country to
sue a vaccine company
so congress passed a law in 1986 and
said
no matter how negligent that company is
no matter how malicious they
are no matter how um toxic the product
you no matter how grievous your injury
you cannot sue them
if you kill somebody if your company
kills somebody in china you're gonna die
yeah out here
and they've set up a whole court system
with some vaseline or some mouthwash or
something an accident somebody get
allergic reaction there you
give you and your business partners your
families your partners too
come on right here boom boom boom you're
dead
and then they say oh you're organs
[Laughter]
they don't play around [ __ ] um so these
you know they can't get caught the only
way that they got caught
on all those other cases is that private
plaintiff's attorneys
sued them on behalf of an injured client
and then during the discovery process
uncovered all this evidence
document showing criminal activity yes
[ __ ] that sounds like some loyal [ __ ]
good [ __ ] man
good lawyer [ __ ] i can hire you i could
hire you
for a case like that that happened to me
i could hire you if that happens to you
yeah or sure we're calling bobby dude
companies you know they don't there's a
reliability
so there's no incentive for them to make
vaccines safe
they don't have to do they don't have to
spend any money on marketing or
advertising because they're mandated for
74 million kids to take whether they
like it or not
right and um and they don't have to
test vaccines it's the only medical
product that doesn't have to be safety
tested
and the reason for that is
it's an artifact of
cdc's legacy as the public health
service
and that agency was a quasi-military
agency that's why people at cdc
have military ranks like surgeon general
and and the vaccine program was
conceived as a national security defense
against a biological attack on our
country so they wanted to make sure if
the russians
attacked us with anthrax or some other
biological agent that we would be able
to quickly formulate a vaccine deploy it
to 200 million
people without regulatory impediments
and so they said if we call it medicine
we need to safety test it let's call it
something else
we'll call it a biologic and we'll
exempt them from safety testing
so the companies when they made this
sort of gold rush
in 1989 to add new vaccines to the
schedule took advantage of that
and said hey we don't have to safely
test these things
and because of that you know we now have
products that nobody knows what the
risks are
we do know that the same year that we
passed all of
that you know they put them on the
schedule you had this explosion of
chronic disease
and you know our children are now the
sickest generation in the history
and cdc is shakes it shrugs its
shoulders
if you say where's this autism epidemic
coming from they say we don't know
right um where is the obesity epidemic
coming from where's the diabetes
epidemic coming from why do our kids
have peanut allergies which
essentially didn't exist prior to 1989.
how about all the attention deficit
stuff yeah and all of that
is directly linked to vaccines in the
scientific literature on our website
we have 1400 studies peer-reviewed
studies
published on nih's website pubmed
linking it to all of linking various
vaccines to all of those injuries so
what are they doing this for money
well they're making 60 billion dollars a
year
selling us vaccines but they're making
500 billion dollars a year
selling the remedies for the injuries
caused by vaccines wow
oh the diabetes medication the adderall
the ritalin the concern um
they at the advert inhalers the
beautiful inhalers the anti-seizure
medications
all of those you know this is a really
great business plan for these companies
you make people sick
and then you sell them a lifetime cure
measles they weren't making any money
if you get measles or chicken pox the
cure is
chicken soup and vitamin a and you can't
patent either of those
and you're well in a week there's
self-limiting illnesses that go away in
a week
but if you can't give somebody that
vaccine and make them
you know diabetic for life and you've
got a permanent customer or
atd or adhd and you know many of the
vaccines are for illnesses for which
there's zero risk a baby a one day old
baby has
zero risk of getting hepatitis b
if his mother doesn't have it yeah which
every mother is tested for
you can only get it from you know
unprotected sex or from sharing needles
so um you know why are we giving one day
old babies
a vaccine for hepatitis b and they admit
the vaccine only lasts five years that
baby
is not gonna have sex with a prostitute
in the first five years of life
there's zero risk and yet it's a very
very dangerous vaccine
and i'm not anti-vaccine i'm very you
know right
i just want safe accidents i want
vaccines tested and what i've said to
people
is test them against a nervous depot not
one of them has ever been
or has them against an unvaccinated
population
so show me a vaccinated population and
an unvaccinated population and show me
that the vaccinated population is
healthier
and if you can do that i will post that
study on my website and i will retire
from this work and go back
to working for a water keeper full time
which is what i want to be doing
yeah yeah well um
you know so many people when you start
talking about this issue will
just screen blasphemy and uh
you know it's really interesting in the
documentary you talk about
how doctors literally know nothing about
what these vaccines actually do or don't
do
or the scientists the doctors themselves
who are saying that you know
we have all these doctors in that film
saying we were taught nothing we were
taught
the vaccines work they're safe they're
effective if you don't give them to
children the children will die
so make sure you give them all to them
right and that's it they're not taught
about what the ingredients are how
they're made what the side effects
are and that's a problem in itself
you know that's a big problem you know
that to me should raise flags for anyone
who has questions about this issue so
you know i think it's also important
like you're saying you're not
anti-vaccine you're talking about let's
look at what's really
going on and let's make better decisions
and
let's have at least something safe going
out to the public and let's have a
public debate
right in america yeah ought to be able
to talk it shouldn't be a sin
or a crime to talk about something yeah
and you know and they called me
and evacs because they have discrediting
me and right
now but i've never said anything to
anybody to make anybody think i'm
anti-fx i've been trying fighting for 35
years
suing people they're getting mercury
out of fish nobody calls me any fish
you know i just want safe fish right and
i want you know vaccines that are safe
too if they work let's show that they
work in an
authentic safety test yeah
yeah it's important man i suggest
everybody go check out this documentary
see
vaxxed one and then check out vax too
and
you know go to my instagram site robert
f kennedy jr.com
and our r jeff kennedy jr and and go to
children's health defense.org because we
have all the science laid out there it's
a very
reader friendly site and you can
actually get the truth air that's
censored
in all of the other social media that's
awesome
man bobby i i can't say
thank you enough i don't know if there's
anything else mike do you have any other
questions man i don't know do you
keep in touch with each other and stuff
that side of your family the family's
still tight we're very tight
our family is very very close there's
now
you know my children's favorite part of
the year we spend
fourth weekend and then a lot of the
summer together and there's about
they have about a hundred and i think
105 cousins
wow you're not in there i've been to
hannah's port before we did um
special olympics there before oh yeah
that's awesome
i was in the dark very close to anthony
anthony's pretty awesome
yeah yes i was in a documentary a few
years ago called
take your pills that maria shriver and
her daughter
christina schwarzenegger produced
tackling adderall
and ritalin and all these deficit
medications because i took a lot of
adderall during my nfl career
which i think was a direct you know that
was me
medicating my cognitive
deficiency through all of the head
trauma and the concussions i had
suffered
and adderall lifted me out of that the
problem was i started to abuse it and it
really [ __ ] me up
through that but so
power to the people man thank you evan
thank you mike thank you uh thank you so
much for your time and
uh you're definitely uh a friend here so
anytime you want to come back you're
more than welcome
thank you thank you thanks for having me
all right everybody well
that was a awesome episode mike
what can you say brother i think this is
really awesome and i'm very grateful
that he came
thank you very much rob me too thank you
for your time
um until next time what are your
websites again
how do they get in touch with you it's
uh my instagram
robert f kennedy jr instagram and
children's health defense childrens.org
children's healthdefense.org
you'd find all the science everything
that's going on stay up to date on
everything there i highly suggest
if you have children and for yourself
just educate yourself
on on the truth of these issues um
until next time everybody i'm evan
britton i'm mike tyson
we're out of here thank you
thanks boys thank you wow
that was awesome
[Music]
[Music]